rarement on aura vu un président du
sénat aussi puissant et avec autant de
cartes en main que dans la période
actuelle avec une assemblée nationale je
dirais qu'elle neutralise et par le fait
même de l'importance de la république en
marche ensemble ça avec un sénat qui
devient un lieu stratégique pour assurer
la réalisation des réformes du
gouvernement agirait la réception de ses
dents de ses réformes dans une chambre
sénatoriale qui devient une forme de
représentation de l'opinion là où
l'assemblée nationale ne l'est plus
tellement parce qu'il ya cette majorité
énorme de la république en marche
monsieur larcher s'ils jouent les choses
habilement et rien ne permet de penser
qu'il ne fera pas parce qu'elle était
très habile 20 périodes récentes
pourrait redonner à la présidence du
sénat et au sénat lui-même à rôle qu'il
a pas eu dans un passé récent et même
depuis assez longtemps sous la vème
république
ça pourrait se renverser en faveur de
l'institution sénatoriales quelle que
soit l'issue de l'élection du 24 70